hey Shiki have you heard the news no
what news about the xpra if you find a
solution to aging you get a really big
prize oh really you've told the right
person tell me more well it's called the
health SP prize and it's the largest
competition in history it's running for
7even years aiming to revolutionize the
way we approach human aging so how was
the winner decided Well I just saw it
explained on this video interviewing
Jamie Justice the Executive Vice
President of this x prise which you
should link below in the description for
it our winning team of the
$11 million ex prise health span you
must demonstrate that your therapeutic
treatment restores muscle cognitive and
immune function and that this is a
minimum of 10 years but a goal Peter's
exponential a goal of 20 years and you
have to show that in person's age 65 to
80 and the therapeutic treatment that
you give it has to take a year or less
so we're going to be measuring that
function before we're going to be
measuring it again at one year and you
have until that time to really move the
needle what we're not going to tell you
is what to do and so you can bring us
anything all right so this can be a drug
that can be a new drug it can be a
repurposed drug it can be a new
combination of either new or repurposed
it could be a biologic it could be a
gene therapy you could be looking at a
cell therapy or a vaccination you might
even have a device maybe you're working
with some kind of fasting mimicking diet
or other nutritional approach um and you
can do one of those alone or in
combination what we're not telling you
is what to do um what we're asking you
to do is to play by these rules if you
want to be considered for an award and
the awarding is indexed right so we're
looking at you have to show an improve
Improvement and function and not not one
but all three again that's muscle
cognitive and immune function wow
awesome so who can apply anyone anyone
anyone I want people from everywhere
jumping in this this is a great
opportunity I mean it could be from our
nonprofit foundations academic and uh in
investigators um from any country um it
could also be commercial for profit
companies so this could be somebody in
the biotech space that might already
actively be working on Therapeutics that
think would um actually help and benefit
aging this could be from groups working
in other disease categories I know of
some folks that working in cancer
oncology that may have some things that
could be repurposed or reconceptualized
toward aging there are also some active
companies and also Academic Teams that
have been working on pieces as you know
in the US there's been a huge huge
increase inrease in the amount spent for
research on Alzheimer's disease trying
to find a cure trying to find a
treatment is that you know there may be
opportunities there that maybe some of
those drugs some of those compounds
might have effects well beyond cognition
and they just need the incentive to
actually try them because we need
options for aging more holistically and
this is a chance to do that so again we
expect anybody the important part of x
prise one of the things that brought me
here
and I think it's so Central to ex prise
this Mission and it's really dear to my
heart is it's
decentralized the next great idea could
come from
anyone love
anywhere anyone that includes me so I
have to find an intervention that
restores muscle cognitive and immune
function by a minimum of 10 years with a
goal of 20 years and the therapeutic
treatment must take less than one year
exactly you in well I have ideas but not
by myself I need a team so if you want
to join my team and want to help out use
the link in the pinned comment or you
know just make a team without me all the
information you need is on the website
wise words Shiki and hopefully it'll be
awesome to see the outcome of this
offense no matter what
happens